hi everyone I'm cobia product manager on
Google Play and I'm Elena engineering
manager on Google Play we work on Play
apps developer team in London today
we're here to tell you how you can set
your app for success using some of the
tools that we provide in Google Play
Developer console will talk about rapid
iteration and experimentation and we'll
tell you how some developers are using
the these services to have success on
play the vision of our team is to build
powerful publishing tools allowing you
to launch and iterate we believe that
experimentation is the key to success
throughout this presentation you'll see
a lot of developer feedback and we'll
start with the feedback we have from
Michael reader as vp business
development at sgn about why the release
genies and gems android first the quick
publishing time on Google Play is the
key you can make multiple submission in
a short time iterating on your product
rapid iteration and experimentation is
the key to success sgn our power users
of tools like beta testing and store
listing experiments we will show you how
other developers are using these tools
and we will share some best practices
sgn user tools and then they utilize
their finding across platforms this
leads to a much more efficient soft
launch process soft launching is a great
way to make sure your app or game
deliver value to your users as a result
their worldwide launch was much more
successful and this is exactly what we
have in mind when we're building those
tools for you our goal is to help you
experiment launch and iterate fast we
got a similar feedback from concrete
software developers of PB a ball and
challenge they've told us the days soft
launch on Android first because it
allows them to iterate faster and to
launch kind of inner in a better way
this is exactly music to our ears
exactly the feedback we like to hear and
a practice we would like to encourage so
what are we going to talk about okay so
we're going to start by talking about
beta testing and some of the
improvements we are making to this
service to make it even easy
to run large beat the programs and to
get feedback from your users then we'll
talk about the best way to roll out
these rapid changes in a safe and
controlled fashion then we go on to talk
about how you can understand your users
using user acquisition report and how
you can optimize your user acquisition
using store listing experiments we will
also talk about the importance of
experimentation if you're looking to go
globally and localize your app to all
the global markets and finally we will
also touch on how you can keep an eye on
the performance with your app on the go
using new play console mobile app
throughout this time throughout the
session will mention new features that
we launched recently or the ones that
we're launching today or very soon okay
so let's start with beta testing um this
is a great way to improve your apps and
games sixty percent of the top 1000 apps
on Google Play are running a beta test
right now and the goal is obviously to
test your apps and games with testers
and early adopters it used to be
challenging in the past to join beta so
we launched close and open beat us with
open beta it's as simple as clicking URL
did you know that there are many big
apps that are running very large open
beta programs for example minecraft uber
Google Search app and many others nice
so here's a great example of a developer
that is using this platform very very
correct in a very correct way hopper and
up helping travelers make better
decisions they run an internal alpha
testing and then a much larger public
beat up beta test and you can see from
their feedback it cuts their testing and
rollout time by half without adding any
extra work for them or their testers
this is exactly what we had in mind when
we built this model we're making it even
easier for users to discover and join
beta testing very soon users will be
able to join beta test directly for your
store listing page on Google Play so if
you run an open beta you can just tell
users go to our page click it there join
our beta and give us feedback feedback
you used to collect feedback through
various sources and had to parse a lot
of information from now on users that
are part of your beta test will be able
to submit private feedback to you
directly through google
play this feedback is private it you can
see it in the Google Play Developer
console it doesn't show to other users
and it doesn't impact your app star
rating now we believe that absent game
should be launched in open beta even
before they go live in production this
is why soon we are going to introduce a
new section on google play called early
access in this section we will feature
exciting apps and games that are still
in development and haven't launched to
production yet this will allow
developers you guys to test your apps
early on with early adopters and
influencers giving you private feedback
making sure you can find product market
fit earlier or find you in your games
kpi's in our first collection we are
going to introduce 28 apps and games you
can see them up here pretty cool icons
we have for example read feed it's an
Android first online book club or we
have Ava the founder were parents and
sisters are deaf creditors help app to
help deaf people and people with hearing
disabilities to participate in real life
conversations then we have lego the kids
and family power brand with their first
ever in-house mobile game it's a 3d Lego
set you can touch twist just like the
brick sets we all grew up with now early
access is not going to be just for
free-to-play never alone a gorgeous game
developed by align media research
together with the alaska natives is
coming to google play on early access
they chose early access because it's a
great way to make sure they get feedback
from their fans and making sure the
gaming experience is a premium one we
are sure those changes that we're doing
to be the testing will help you create
larger vita tests making your apps and
games even more awesome ok kobe
mentioned that users will be able to
give private feedback on open beta apps
i know you all know how important it is
to listen to use your feedback and to
act on it recently we have launched a
number of improvements to user reviews
functionality in Google Play Developer
console allowing you to for example
search your reviews by keyword or for
example to see various breakdowns of
rating aggregates by a number of
different
engines for example device country app
version and so on in addition to that we
made it possible to sign up for
notifications for email notifications if
you when users change their review after
your reply I'm happy to announce that
today we launch review analysis these
are further improvements to user reviews
functionality in Google Play Developer
console and they come in several
different tools one of them is
benchmarks across number of fixed
aspects for example the design stability
or speed so it's basically allows you to
compare how your app is doing comparing
to other similar apps on these fixed
aspects in addition to this we also
launched unique topics so analyzing all
of your user reviews and trying to
extract what are those specific topics
that users are talking about just for
your app ok let's talk about release
management tools sounds good cool so you
beat the test your app you address bunch
of user feedback and now you want to
launch a production in this critical
moment in time we want to be there for
you we want to give you as much support
as we can so you can roll out in a very
safe and controlled fashion one feature
that I want to add that I want to remind
everyone of is staged rollouts staged
rollouts allow you to roll out gradually
keeping an eye on the performance of
your app so that you can hold in case of
any issues in case issues do happen and
we all know that they do you will be
able to hold and you will only unhold if
you like very very specifically if you
do that action or upload new set of apks
and here is one power tip when you start
to staged rollout we select a random
percentage of users who become eligible
for this new update if you increase the
percentage we add more users to the to
the randomly selected set if you start
the next stage rollout we use a
completely different seed which means
it's not always the same set of users
getting less stable versions so you
don't have to worry about that for
example you can see how developers like
FDX games you staged rollouts to
confidently rollout and frequently roll
out new versions of their act
okay so since we're talking about
release management I want to mention
another feature we launched recently
called time publishing we know that you
appreciate the quick publishing times
available on Google Play but we wanted
to do better meaning giving you exact
control on the moment your app update
goes live with time publishing you can
make as many changes like apk changes
store listing updates as you wish we
batch all the changes and they don't go
live until you click the go live button
in the Google Play Developer console
when you click it the changes go live
within minutes you also have a changes
log showing you exactly what changes are
about to go live which is a great way to
manage your release you can see the
feedback for Flair games here showing us
how this feature is super useful for
them okay now let's talk about
understanding visits to your store
listing page in Google Play it's very
important to understand where you your
users are coming from and some time last
year we launched user acquisition funnel
this panel allows you to see how many of
visitors to your store listing page are
being converted to installers and how
many of those installers are then
converting to to become enough
purchasers in addition to this you can
further break down this report by for
example user acquisition source or
channel for example seeing whether users
are coming from Playstore organically or
from different channels like advertising
I'm pretty sure that like trulia so far
you found this report to be very useful
and since understanding where your users
are coming from be so important a couple
of weeks ago we have launched another
improvement to to this funnel which
allows you to break it down by country
this is very important because it allows
you to localize your app in a more
efficient way and to take it one step
further we're happy to announce that
very soon we will be launching
conversion funnel benchmarks this will
allow you to compare how your app is
doing against other similar apps in in
in terms of how efficiently it's
converting users from visitors to stores
in page 22 installers stay tuned this is
coming very soon and once you see who's
visiting your store listing page you'll
want to optimize right
Yeah right okay so let's talk about
getting you some more users to do that
we want to make sure that your store
listing really shows off your app in the
best possible light and in order to get
to the best store listing we need to
experiment this is where store listing
experiments come in this feature has
been a very big success with developers
in the past year more than seventy
percent of our top developers are using
the feature we often get feedback from
developers for example like this one
from good game studios that it drives
significant uplift to their conversion
rate a big opportunity to get more
installs is optimizing the top of the
funnel your store listing page this is
where users make their install decision
regardless of whether they found the app
from search or via deep link before we
launch it you had to use a bunch of
workarounds and spend some budget you
can see the feedback from Rovio here how
they had to run I contest and spend
budget after we launched it you can see
their feedback about soft launching
first on google play as it allows them
to better understand their users store
listing page have been seeing started
seeing experience have been seen great
success in the last year you can see
Flair games up here thirty percent
increase in installs irri public labs
running this exactly the way we thought
about it as a rapid iteration and
experimentation tools expedia ten
percent increase of installs globally
and actually their most successful test
of reordering screenshots here are some
best practices when running store
listing experiments create a hypothesis
first make sure you know what you're
trying to do to prove next test one
thing at a time run your experiments
until they they have reached statistical
significance will let you know when this
has happened minor tweaks often have
minor impact consider bold changes
especially if you're early in your
startup's life and finally keep testing
the next major improvement may be still
to come here is some great feedback we
received from Jamie burger head of
marketing at scope Lee you can see how
this feature encourages testing and
validation of new and bold ideas we're
very happy to see how they use this is
there a go-to tool for market testing
and
okay so here's some great example of the
best practices in action with instacart
we've learned that an apt description
that clearly shows your app value to
users just works better so you can see
control versus experiment experiments is
much clearer plus fourteen percent in
installs and here's a bunch of great
examples from concrete software
sometimes you just get lucky they run an
icon test for NHL hockey target smash
plus seventy percent installs boom it's
great right but sometime you actually
need to launch iterate and experiment a
lot so with PBA bowling challenge define
a series of experiments and every icon
that you see here represent is a
complete series of experiments they'll
also iterate it on their description
screenshots in their order leading to a
compound effect of sixty-three percent
this is incredible now let's see an
example from mixie a leading game
developer from Japan that will show us
how a leading game developer thinks
about localization and experimentation
when mixie wanted to take their big hit
monster strike to the US they run a
series of experiment they tested the
icon the screenshots the description and
the video in this chart you can see how
they run the experiments methodically
and scientifically leading to a compound
effect on sixty-eight percent in
installs store listing experiments mixie
understand the difference in taste and
flavor between users in the US and users
in japan and help them localized their
games much better and here's the
feedback we got from their ex flag
studio team this feedback makes us
really excited is our mission is to help
you test directly on our platform we
want you to experiment we want you to
iterate and we want you to do this fast
this is why I'm happy to announce that
last week we launched multiple
concurrent localized store listing
experiments we want you to go globally
faster and have better tools to test
localized versions of your store listing
you can now run up to five experiments
with different languages at the same
time awesome so you're talking about
making things faster right in the one
thing that is not fast today is making
price changes in the developer
so this really sucks actually because
lots of people have the same price point
too many inner products or paid apps so
what are we going to do about that I'm
very glad you asked Kobe we want to make
this faster as well we want to make
price and faster as well so I'm also
happy to announce that earlier this week
we have launched pricing templates with
pricing templates you can define prices
across all of the market google play
supports you guys know there are 70 such
markets now once you create a template
you can link it to as many paid apps or
inner products as you want if you make a
change the template it gets propagated
2222 all the apps so for example if
you're like talk about games and selling
multiple titles that let's let's say 299
you only need to make changes to your
template once and it will be properly
propagated to all of your apps if you're
like googa selling in a product and
multiple price points for example 199
499 and 999 you only need to maintain
three templates and instead of manually
making changes to tens or hundreds of
individual pricing points in multiple
different currencies like in this
feedback we got from toca Boca weho
pricing templates will help you move
faster and get successful okay so it's
important for us you're also able to
localize your price better this is why
we also launched round pricing with
round pricing we're not like we used to
do just converting the price using
today's exchange rate we also apply
locally relevant country-specific
rounding rules so a price like nine
point seventy three euros become 999
euros a price like 196 japanese yen
simply becomes 200 Japanese yen and
25,000 235 indonesian rupiah simply
becomes 25,000 indonesian rupiah we are
sure that this change like the feedback
you see here from google will help you
streamline your pricing structures and
make your businesses even better now
while we were helping you make price
changes faster with templates and more
locally relevant with rounding we're
keeping your ability to tweak the prices
manually in the developer console we
know that this is important for you when
you run
short time promotion or try new pricing
strategies we are sure that the new
changes we are making to pricing will
help you go globally faster okay last
but not least finally we have a mobile
app for Google Play Developer console we
have to admit it took us a while it took
us much longer than it took all of you
guys but we've made it and we can tell
you this app stuff is pretty sweet we
really like it now our new app allows
you to follow your apps performance on
the go and to do time critical changes
wherever you are when you rapidly
iterating you need a power tool that's
in your pocket at all times and we've
built play console app exactly those use
cases in mind what do we want to quickly
reply to use a review or show off
performance of your app to a venture
capitalist play console app should be
there to support you regarding an
initial feature set obviously you can
see you can track installs and uninstall
and you can break them down by a number
of dimensions like at version country
device and so on you can also track your
crash reports including hourly data and
full stack traces you can also see
ratings and user reviews and you can
reply to user reviews you can also track
the state of your release for example is
it in vida testing is it in staged
rollout or has it reached prod yet oh
and one more thing you can obviously get
push notifications everyone loves those
when there are certain important changes
you are to your app for example when
you're up updates go live if you haven't
installed the app yet please do if
you're still not convinced please come
to play sandbox we would love to
convince you and if you have any
feedback send it to us we intend to
listen and add more functionality in the
next couple of versions okay so today we
spoke about launching experimenting and
iterating on google play with the new
changes we're going to introduce to beta
test it will become easier for users to
discover and join your vita programs and
for you to build bigger larger bit
audiences and improve your apps and
games users will be able to send you
private feedback that only you can see
in the developer console the new early
access section will feature exciting
apps and games that are still in
development we also spoke about better
understanding your users with our new
mobile apps that
and I just mentioned and a bunch of
enhancements such as benchmark to the
user acquisition report finally we spoke
about making things faster with multiple
localized store listing experiments and
price templates as well as making prices
more locally relevant with rounding we
are really excited to getting developer
feedback like the one you see here from
Scott Rubin SVP of business development
at roblox telling us how telling us how
features like store listing experiments
encourage them to launch their next
major update on Android first we hope
that the tools we're building will
encourage you to continue to launching
and iterating on our platform we will
continue to help building more powerful
publishing tools allowing you to
experiment iterate and make your apps
and games even more awesome thank you
thank you now I would like to invite to
the stage Larissa and Erin thank you
thanks Melina and Kobe that was an
amazing overview of all the cool stuff
launching in the developer console you
can see the Aaron and I are really
excited about this talk today so much so
that we decided to dress the part how
you doin there in d my name is Larissa
and I lead business development for the
apps team at Google Play my team and I
work with developers to help them build
great apps and successful businesses on
the platform and I'm Aaron I leave
search and discovery on Play my team is
focused on making sure users find great
apps much as I love short round I'm
gonna take the hat off so I can see you
guys so I talk to developers all the
time and understanding how store
discovery works always comes up as an
important topic we know that it can feel
difficult to break through the noise and
to help users find your app exactly the
right time more apps are being uploaded
to the store every day making it even
harder to break through and studies show
that more users are using the same set
of apps over and over again
set of downloading new ones one theory
is that app fatigue is driving this but
what if it's at users simply can't find
all the great apps that are out there
and it's not only apps that are growing
the entire Android ecosystem is growing
incredibly fast you heard some of these
numbers this morning the one we're going
to talk about here is 1 billion monthly
store users out of that huge audience we
want to help you find the best users for
your app so that's why you're all here
today we're going to walk through how we
can work together to improve app
discovery in the Play Store there are a
lot of important elements that
contribute to discovery some of which
you've already heard about but we're
going to touch on a few of them again
because there's that important because
they directly contribute to discovery
we've narrowed them down to the most
critical and we're going go through each
of them build something great listen to
your users optimize your presence and
expand your reach and then we're going
to share some insights about how the
discovery mechanisms in the store
actually work some of which we've never
shared before so as Larissa mentioned it
all starts with building something great
we want users to find the apps they will
love so a quarter of installed apps are
used only once wow that's scarier than a
pit of snakes all right Erin let's let's
turn it back anyways anyways I promise
no more so this is why we want to start
with building something great so based
on some internal analysis we found that
permissions footprint oh excuse me we
found that permissions footprint and
design were all key components when it
came to a user's perception of a great
app so starting with permissions
excessive permissions can actually deter
a user from installing your app in the
first place it's important to remember
if you don't need it don't ask for it
users may be wary of installing apps
where the permissions don't seem to
align with the app functionality for
example why does a child's game need
access my phone's call logs second is
footprint some users may be scared off
by the footprint of your app these users
may be on poor internet connections or
have limited phone memory this is
especially true in emerging markets
where there are both phone and network
limitations so it's helpful to be
mindful of SDK compatibility apk size
and memory usage sometimes less is more
third is designed so the users installed
your app now you want to ensure a great
experience so remember to limit the
cognitive load a well-designed app is
intuitive and consistent and does not
require a user to hunt guess remember or
otherwise strain their brains trying to
figure out how to interact with your app
one tangible solution for making a
highly usable app is implementing
Google's design spec known as material
design your two examples of apps that
invested more in quality by adopting
material design which led to the benefit
of more user engagement it's pretty
impressive for example that Trello saw
forty-one percent increase in activity
per session by implementing material
design so you can do your best to build
a great app but how can you be sure it's
actually great more than half of poor
user reviews or quality related and a
third of those are just about bugs and
crashes it can be difficult to get it
right in the first iteration so we
recommend following the earlier advisor
milena and Coby and using beta testing
and staged rollouts to ensure that your
app is great when it launches so we've
covered building and launching a great
app now just because your app is
launched it doesn't mean you need to
stop engaging with your users
listening to your users is important for
continued success I'm going to explain
why you have a unique opportunity and
Android to engage with the users
directly by replying to the reviews via
the developer console and building an
even more loved app as a result one
example is aviary who created a dialogue
with their users by engaging with
feedback this responsiveness led to a
fifty percent of reviewers revising
their scores higher it's crazy right use
your feedback can help make your app
better leading to higher ratings and a
boost in discovery opportunities so
after building a great app and listening
to your users it's important to create a
Play Store listing that quickly and
accurately reflects what your app is
about you're all familiar with the
different elements of your listing these
really require some thoughtful attention
we provide in multiple ways for you to
communicate the value of your app and is
up to you to try to capture the most
important and interesting information
and each of them from the title to the
description to the images provide
metadata that help us understand what
your app does and who's most likely to
use it it sounds easy but no one gets it
right the first time and this is why we
created store listing experiments to
help you refine each of these elements
you already heard from Kobe and milayna
about how these have help developers
over the last year in the stat that
seventy percent of top developers are
using experiments is really incredible
developers of all sizes are seeing real
impact an iteration is key for store
listing experiments in this example from
Rovio they focus on the icon and finding
which one with most impact conversions
here are 12 different treatments they
explored with various outcomes and they
kept iterating this is what we see from
developers who are finding the most
success they continue to test and refine
and understand user preferences
ultimately rodeo saw significant uplift
as a result of their experiments and
back to discovery higher conversion
rates from your listing two installs are
important signal and help us understand
when a user is successfully gone from
searching for an app to finding one that
they think they'll love so now you built
a great app you've implemented important
feedback and you have a strong place to
our presence what's next there are
different opportunities to expand your
reach depending on the type of app you
have and the type of experience is that
your users are looking for going global
and finding audiences in new markets is
a strategy that's worked extremely well
for many developers so we're going to
explore a few tips and tools that can
help you find success in new markets so
earlier we talked about the massive
reach of Android we've actually looked
at the growth rates of apps that are
available globally and those that are
only available in specific markets
global apps through 2.4 times faster
than non-global apps now this makes
intuitive sense if you're more markets
you have a larger addressable audience
but the data really proves it out there
are a few specific things to consider
when you're planning to localize your
app first you should use the dev console
report that we talked about to
understand where new user bases are
growing and prioritize localizing for
those markets second don't just
translate actually localize this means
ensure that you're culturally aware of
local market expectations and be ready
to support your new users last always be
prepared to test and iterate new users
means new feedback a developer who did
incredibly well with this is one
password they localize their store
description their screenshots the
content and the messaging inside their
app and we looked at those signals to
understand when the app was ready to be
shown to local users for one password
the investment really paid off after two
weeks of work they saw a 100x install
growth in Korea
it's really pretty incredible by
focusing on local market users we made a
real difference and in most cases it's
worth the effort if your plan is to grow
through market expansion and we have
powerful tools to help like the
localization checklist access to
translation services and the new pricing
features that Kobe shared so we reviewed
the most important ways that you can
directly affect the discoverability of
your app and some key actions that you
can take right away for build something
great limit permissions and focus on
beautiful design listen to your users
feedback is a gift use it to get better
optimize your presence experiment your
way to improve conversions and expand
your reach go global and local eyes
we've also mentioned that all of these
impact discovery within the store so
let's unpack how the store actually
works and why each of these elements
matter oh there we go I'm back great so
how are users actually discovering apps
and play and what matters to those
discovery mechanisms so let's start with
how users are actually finding apps
today the top discovery channels on play
our number-one play search two
recommendations three top charts so
starting with search about half of
searches are specifically for a nap
title this is where it's especially
important when naming your app to be
unique keep it short and make sure that
it is not easily confused with a
similarly named app a well named app
also has the benefit of appearing within
Google Play search suggest which makes
it even easier for users to find your
app by using Google Play search your
guests they don't even need to type in
the full name to find the app fo
searches are also by category or keyword
this is where it's important
to make sure you select the right app
category also when you're writing the
description of your app it's great it
important to be thorough and complete
making sure to include key functionality
and features you may have noticed
there's actually a third way that an app
can appear within a given within given
search results and this is ads play
search ads are already part of AdWords
app add install campaigns and provide an
additional placement within play search
so recommendations whether on the
homepage or right after a user installs
an app Google Play recommends apps
personalized for each user although
there are a lot of components that go
into those smarts I just want to
highlight a few for you today these
include metadata app quality users store
activity and web knowledge the charts
are a common way for both new and return
returning users to gain a quick
understanding of which apps are popular
in the store and which apps are on their
way to becoming popular so we're going
to share some insight into how these
charts are put together with specific
details on key components top free and
top paid charts are primarily determined
by installs within the last seven days
we've kept this timeline fairly short
because we want the charts to stay fresh
and interesting week-over-week top new
free and top new paid also look at bakit
installs over the previous seven days
but they're biased towards new apps
those that have launched on the store in
the previous 30 days this is important
to make sure the charts aren't dominated
by established titles we want users to
help you want to help users find new and
interesting apps wherever they look for
them trending on the other hand
identifies fast risers that have the
potential to make it under the top
charts typically this means that their
installs have seen accelerated growth
over the previous 30 days but they're
absolute installs might not be as large
as those on the other top charts
and finally top-grossing uses a sem
attend a trailing approach but is
instead determined by spend and of
course we're always tuning our
algorithms to produce the best user
experience so these are subject to
change but hopefully you have a better
sense of what drives placement of the
top charts and how we look at user
preference to determine which apps to
surface featuring everybody loves
featuring so we define featuring to mean
the collections that appear across the
store either manually curated or
algorithmically generated quality is the
key driver for inclusion and that's why
we spent the first half of this talk
focus on tools and strategies to help
drive important quality signals in
addition to quality we also want to
surface trending apps to keep the store
fresh and we definitely want users to
find apps are using the latest Android
features things that truly make their
experience and their phone special if
you meet the necessary quality bar your
app is eligible for appearing in certain
collections where it makes contextual
sense if it's a category or a topic
where were users have installed similar
apps with an even higher expectation of
quality we have collections showcasing
new and updated apps so users know
they're getting great experiences that
are hot off the presses for seasonal
collections and special promotions our
BDM merchandising teams work together to
identify which apps to include and we
also use a healthy dose of machine
learning to scale our efforts across
categories and markets it's important to
note that within each of these
collections the recommendations engine
helps determine which users see which
apps the most important thing is not
that millions of users see your app it's
that millions of the right users see
your app and go on to install it so now
that we revealed the holy grail of app
discovery we want to leave you with four
recommendations that you can do right
now number one for building excuse me
number one for building a great app we
recommend reviewing and roar
it's design principles does your app
measure up to four listening to your
users we recommend addressing user
feedback especially when it comes to
bugs squash those bugs number three for
optimizing your presence why not try a
store listing experiment and finally
number four for expanding your reach we
recommend reviewing the market report in
the developer console so that's our talk
for today we are so excited to have you
all here we know we shared a lot of
content with you but the great news is
that you can find everything you need in
our new app playbook by google play it
replaces the business guide that some of
you have seen called the secrets to app
success on Google Play there are 10 of
great features but it's brand new so we
would love your feedback if you get a
moment please hop over to the google
play store and try it out and of course
you want to leave you with a few helpful
links thank you so much for coming from
all of us